good evening police searching for the
mother of the child whose body was found
here a nationwide search is underway as
we're now learning the identity of that
child victim
thanks for joining us here at five i'm
denise faldis and i'm brian loftis the
i-team's vanessa murphy live now at
metro police headquarters she joins us
with the very latest
police say seven-year-old liam houstead
was killed and his body was dumped
they're now calling his
own mother the suspect they say she was
last seen in the denver area and they
are
asking for the public's help now this is
a photo of the child liam husted he's
from the san jose
area lieutenant ray spencer says he and
his mother 35-year-old samantha moreno
rodriguez
left san jose on may 24th the child's
body was then found near a trail between
las vegas and perum four days later
police say moreno rodriguez may be
driving this 2007
dark blue dodge which may be packed with
belongings
according to lieutenant spencer the
child's father
is not a suspect i spoke with the father
about 60 minutes ago before i came out
here
because i didn't want him to see this
press conference without me explaining
what was about to transpire
i will tell you it's a heartbreaking
conversation to have
this has been an emotional last 10 days
for myself
all the investigators that have been
working on it and we're just glad we're
able to get some closure for liam
and then hold the person responsible for
this crime
lieutenant spencer is asking anyone who
may recognize the mother they could have
seen her
in the las vegas valley maybe on the
27th or 28th
driving that dark blue vehicle he's also
asking anyone who may work in a hotel or
motel
to take a closer look saying perhaps she
could have checked in
anyone with information is urged to call
crime stoppers that number is
but he 702-385-5555 to the ongoing
investigation and says
any information can help reporting live
vanessa murphy
8 news now